joe hearts were heavy here today as
trooper micah may was officially
laid to rest this was the end of this
day dedicated to his service here in
southern nevada
now his casket was brought in and
saluted at the beginning of this
ceremony
again saluted and honored for his
service here in southern nevada
the ceremony also involved a helicopter
flyover before trooper may was lowered
into the ground
his widow joanna may was handed and
handed a folded american flag
so she and her children could say their
final goodbyes nevada highway patrol
says this moment wasn't just important
to honor trooper may
but also to remind his family that all
of las vegas
is behind them this is our
opportunity to show his family how much
he meant to not just this
agency but to the las vegas community
and the state of nevada
this is a man who
laid his luck on the line and didn't get
to go home after shift
while he was out protecting this
community and that means a lot and it's
important that the family
knows how much that matters to us
trooper smacka also said this beautiful
event is a symbol of our city's heart
and ability to come together in times of
unimaginable grief
there was also a riderless horse here to
symbolize
a fallen hero here locally and of course
trooper smackus said
though trooper may is gone he will never
be forgotten
reporting live tonight sasha loftis 8
news now